the newest episode for Guild Wars 2 got
my attention haven't played any version
of Guild Wars before but it has a few
things I haven't seen from other MMOs so
I gave it a shot I boosted to level 80
to experience the new content and while
I really don't know what came in Guild
Wars before I really enjoyed my play
experience with it ArenaNet calls the
content editions they give to existing
players living world they add free
content including weapons zones
instances and upgradeable armor to each
expansion but that doesn't mean your old
gear or the old zones are useless which
is unlike many mmo's the progress you
make stays as progress so you don't need
to grind incessantly to experience the
new editions each living world episode
introduces new maps stories and features
to the game for max level players the
game was really easy to get into as
there are a ton of things to keep me
occupied and not making videos so let's
get into it before I get sucked back in
here are three reasons you should be
playing Guild Wars 2 number one episodes
as a veteran of a few nmo RPGs my test
to see if I want to continue playing one
is the questing experience through the
first zone are the stories instances and
events engaging do I understand who I am
and what I'm doing there do I even care
if the answer to all these questions is
yes then I'll settle down for a bit to
see where the story takes me Guild Wars
2 meets all of these requirements and
immediately feels good putting you into
an actual living world that even without
a pre-existing knowledge base is easy to
get swept up in the narrative is set in
the alone Ian's desert which was
apparently the scene of an entire
expansion from the original Guild Wars
250 years ago in game time to catch up
new players for some time the world of
Tyria has been caught between an undead
king named yoko awesome name right
a rogue god named Balthazar and an evil
elder dragon named Crockett auric who
turns things and people into these
crystal and shadow monsters Balthazar
has been recently destroyed but the
trouble is stayed the land is so scarred
by Krakatoa it visibly divides sections
of the map and completely changes
landscapes like in this rad zone called
the gi Bluffs the rest of the zone is
these gorgeous cliffs and waterfalls but
parts of the zone that have been
affected by the dragon bran looked like
hell if hell was
of purple crystal the last release for
living world content added a new mount
called the roller beetle which damages
enemys you rollover and eventually can
even knock down walls to reveal hidden
areas in this release they added a new
mastery skill that allows for more uses
of your mouse
skill so for the roller beetle that
means faster rolling for longer in the
path of fire expansion the zones are
larger than anything in Guild Wars
before an arena net did that because the
mounts that created needed a big space
to play in these are an MMO regular look
cool go faster than walking mounts
although they do look cool and give you
a speed boost they open up the world for
exploration in a different way each of
the six new mounts released within path
of fire has a unique function and skill
masteries which can be upgraded by doing
quests and puzzles specifically designed
for each one the Raptor mount jumps
horizontally across large gaps while the
Springer which is a freakin big bunny
jumps vertically some of the zones have
areas that can only be reached by
utilizing each mount and this makes the
play experience feel kind of like a
platformer which I love more than just
helping you reach new areas the mounts
actually change the way you approach the
world when you're riding one you see a
mountain you go I can probably climb
that where in other MMOs you go that's
just a piece of scenery another unique
thing to this living world stuff is that
it changes some instances based on what
you've completed or done in the
storyline I haven't seen that before in
other MMOs so it seems like arena and
that's all about unique game aspects
number 2 more than just story each of
the living world episodes brings new
content in the form of story progression
for your character isn't a bunch of
features everything from raids and five
player dungeons which in Guild Wars 2
are called fractals two new armor sets
legendary weapons and I'm sure some
other systems and these updates are free
for players who own the game it's called
living world because the world of Guild
Wars continually changes in each episode
so there's always something to do or
experience that you haven't seen yet for
example in Episode four of path of fire
there's a new raid called myth right
gambit in which you get to fight a genie
actually it's called a Djinn which I
guess is just a bad genie there's a new
legendary weapon that I think is called
quick waddle that covers the ground in a
missed and lets you summon a flying
snake and I want it
along with episodes there are also
limited time festivals for holidays so
you can get into the spirit of the
season and balance passes for previous
content so everything stays nice and
orderly number three it's easy to start
as I mentioned I boosted to level 80
before starting to play a free level
boost is included with the path afire
expansion most MMOs are so far end of
themselves that starting from scratch is
really hard due to complicated play or
indecipherable maps and high gear
requirements Guild Wars has features
that are made to ease you into the new
world and get you started guides show
you each point of interest on a map and
talk you through why you're going there
the mini-map is easy to understand and
the missions list is organized as a noob
the down mechanic is easily my favorite
thing in the game how many times have
you died right before killing the mob
you were fighting only to run back from
wherever you were teleported to to find
the monster with full health and ready
to kill you again Guild Wars has a
mechanic that allows you to fight for a
short time after getting knocked down
and revive yourself if you secure a kill
fighting for your own survival puts you
on the edge of your seat not knowing if
you'll make it it's really rewarding
when you do the ridiculously helpful
player base of guild wars also eases
your introduction into the game it's
definitely one of the best game
communities I've ever been a part of
shout out to my guild VIP thank you guys
so much for welcoming me and teaching me
everything this game is a wealth of fun
when paired with the fact that it's
supposed to be enjoyed with a guild I
can really see why many people have
played it from the beginning and why
people are still picking it up now if
you'll excuse me my beetle needs a walk
or a roll or whatever